Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory Is History and Happy New Year. We have finally reached 2022 and we've finally reached the 1st of January in our 12 or 13 days of Christmas. So Tom, Tom Holland, to bring in the new year, what jolly, upbeat, laugh-a-minute story have you chosen for us?
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory。历史与新年快乐。我们终于迎来了2022年，在我们的12天或13天圣诞节里，我们也终于迎来了1月1日。那么汤姆，汤姆·霍兰德，为了迎接新年，你给我们选了一个怎样欢快、乐观、让人捧腹的故事呢？
Well, it's a Roman story, and I think that's appropriate because we celebrate the 1st of January as the new year because of the Romans. Was it the first day of the year for them? Was that March, I thought? Yes, it was, but it was the first day of the civil year. So it's when the consuls, who are the two magistrates who in during the republican period um served as the
嗯，这是一个关于罗马的故事，我觉得这很贴切，因为我们是因为罗马人才把1月1日庆祝为新年。对他们来说，这是当年的第一天吗？我以为那是三月？是的，确实如此，但这是民用历法的第一年。所以当执政官——也就是在共和国时期担任
kind of preeminent magistrates in the republic it's when they took office um and um from the second century bc onwards and increasingly under the caesars it comes to be enshrined as the start of the of the more generally as well. So I think we talked about that, didn't we? We talked on an episode about New Year and about Janus, the twost of January is not only the day in which the consuls head up onto the capital, which is the sacred hill with the great shrine of Jupiter and sacrifices made there and the auguries are taken and people look to the future.
共和国中最高长官的两位行政长官——上任时，嗯，从公元前二世纪开始，并在凯萨统治下愈发深入人心，它逐渐被确立为更普遍意义上的开始。所以我想我们讨论过这个，对吧？我们在有一期节目里谈论过新年和雅努斯（Janus），1月1日不仅是执政官前往卡пито利山（Capitollio）的日子，那座神圣的山上有朱庇特（Jupiter）的神庙，人们在那里举行祭祀、进行占卜并展望未来。
But it's also a day in which offerings are kind of made, sacrifices are made to the good of Caesar. Right. And in AD 68, that is the year, it's the last year of Nero's life. And he goes up there. And notoriously what happens on that day is, first of all, they can't find the keys to the temple. That's ominous. So that's ominous.
但这也是一种向凯撒的福祉奉献祭品、进行牺牲的日子。没错。而在公元68年，也就是尼禄生命的最后一年。他上山了。而那一天众所周知发生的事情是，首先，他们找不到神庙的钥匙。这很不吉利。所以这很不吉利。
That's ominous so that's literally ominous that's ominous but the other the other ominous thing that happens is that um sporus who um friend of the show the uh the poor boy who has been castrated and turned into the spitting image of nero's dead wife papaya sabina um as a gift gives nero um a ring on which Persephone is shown being raped by Hades, the king of the underworld, and taken down into the depths of the kingdom of the dead. It's quite a strong present, I would say. Well, yes, all kinds of subliminal messages. Especially what's been going on with sporus yes exactly so it's it's a kind of it's a it's remembered subsequently as a somber moment uh where nero's downfall which happens um
这很不吉利，所以这简直太不吉利了，这很不吉利，但另一件发生的不吉利的事是，嗯，斯波鲁斯（Sporus）——节目老朋友、那个被阉割并被整得像尼禄死去的妻子波帕娅·萨比娜（Poppaea Sabina）一模一样的可怜男孩——作为礼物送给尼禄一枚戒指，上面刻着冥界之王哈迪斯（Hades）强暴珀耳塞福涅（Persephone）、将其带入死者王国深处的画面。这是一份挺震撼的礼物，我得说。嗯，是的，充满了各种潜意识的信息。尤其是关于斯波鲁斯身上发生的事，嗯，没错，所以这随后被当作一个阴暗的时刻被人们铭记，嗯，尼禄的垮台就是在
over the course of the following months uh is set in train um and it's set in train by a a gallo roman aristocrat called julius vindex who declares that you know that Nero's, he's beyond the pale, he's gone too far. He's raising the banner of rebellion. And this serves to trigger a rebellion in Spain and encourages an old school kind of figure of Republican aristocratic virtue called Galba, who is the governor of one of the provinces in Spain to declare himself emperor.
接下来的几个月里开始酝酿的，嗯，它是由一个名叫尤利乌斯·温代克斯（Julius Vindex）的高卢-罗马贵族挑起的，他宣称尼禄已经不可救药，太过分了。他举起了叛乱的旗帜。这引发了西班牙的叛乱，并鼓励了一位老派的共和派贵族美德化身——加尔巴（Galba），他是西班牙某个行省的总督，他宣布自己为皇帝。
Nero is toppled, commits suicide, and the Senate accept Galba as emperor. And Galba crosses from Spain through Gaul down through Italy and enters Rome. And so on the 1st of January, 69 AD, he is the emperor. So he is going through the rituals that the year before Nero had done now these rituals do not just take place in Rome they take place in cities across the empire and most significantly they take place in legionary bases and these legionary bases are dotted mainly around the frontiers, not exclusively, but mainly. And the largest concentration of these legionary bases are along the Rhine, because the Rhine obviously is adjacent to Germany that the Romans had attempted to conquer. They then lost three legions to Varus in AD 9.
尼禄被推翻，自杀身亡，元老院接受加尔巴为皇帝。加尔巴从西班牙穿过高卢，向下穿过意大利进入罗马。因此，在公元69年1月1日，他就是皇帝。所以他正在重复尼禄前一年做过的那些仪式。现在，这些仪式不仅在罗马举行，它们在帝国各地的城市中举行，最重要的是，它们在军团基地举行，而这些军团基地主要分布在边境周围，虽然不全是，但主要是。这些军团基地最集中的地方是莱茵河沿岸，因为莱茵河显然毗邻罗马人曾试图征服的日耳曼尼亚。他们在公元9年向瓦鲁斯（Varus）损失了三个军团。
Varus's three legions had been lost to Arminius in AD 9. Teutoburg Forest. Teutoburg Forest. And the Romans kind of, they inflict devastating punishment on the Germans for it. And they essentially decided the Germans don't deserve to be conquered. That's their attitude. So they build these line of bases along the Rhine.
瓦鲁斯的三个军团在公元9年败给了阿米尼乌斯（Arminius）。条顿堡森林。条顿堡森林。罗马人为此对日耳曼人进行了毁灭性的惩罚。他们基本上决定日耳曼人不值得被征服。这就是他们的态度。所以在莱茵河沿岸，他们建立了一系列这样的基地。
And that means that there's a huge concentration of manpower there. Now, these Rhine legions, they had marched against Julius Vindex in the summer, not because they were loyal to Nero, but because they saw Julius Vindex not as a Roman, but as a Gallic rebel. And there'd been attempts to negotiate, but basically between the commander of the Rhine legions and Julius Vindex. But the legions wanted to have a punch up. They want, basically they wanted, you know, they wanted a chance to wipe out Julius Vindex's men who were all Gauls. Right.
这意味着那里集中了大量的人力。现在，这些莱茵河军团曾在夏天对抗尤利乌斯·温代克斯，不是因为他们忠于尼禄，而是因为他们把尤利乌斯·温代克斯视为高卢叛军，而不是罗马人。双方曾试图进行谈判，主要是莱茵河军团指挥官和尤利乌斯·温代克斯之间。但军团想要打一架。基本上他们想要，你知道的，他们想要一个消灭尤利乌斯·温代克斯手下士兵的机会，那些人全都是高卢人。没错。
And that would then license them to plunder Gaul. I was about to say, there must be some reason they're just fighting. There must be booty. They would have a big punch to plunder Gaul. I was about to say, there must be some reason other than just fighting. There must be booty. Yeah, they would have a big punch and they want booty. Yeah. And they're not allowed to do this. And basically it's Galba who stops them from doing it.
然后这就会授权他们去洗劫高卢。我正要说，他们打仗肯定是有原因的。一定有战利品。他们会大打出手去洗劫高卢。我正要说，除了打仗肯定还有别的原因。一定有战利品。是的，他们会大干一场并想要战利品。是的。而他们不被允许这样做。基本上是加尔巴阻止了他们这样做。
And Galba sends them packing back to the Rhine bases. So they're really, really cross about this. And they're further, they dislike Galba because Galba had been in command on the Rhine frontier and he was a tremendous kind of martinet. He was, you know, an old school stickler
所以加尔巴打发他们回莱茵河基地。因此他们对此真的、真的非常生气。而且他们更加不喜欢加尔巴，因为加尔巴曾在莱茵河边境担任指挥官，他是一个极其严厉的军纪督察。他是一个，你知道的，老派的死板教条主义者。
and they didn't like it. He was, he was kind of, legionaries were perfectly capable of respecting stern disciplinarians, but they had to be charismatic as well.
他们不喜欢这样。他，军团士兵完全有能力尊重严厉的纪律严明者，但他们也必须具有个人魅力。
In this kind of football manager, you know, Dominic, all that stuff that you were doing when you should have been. You're comparing Galba's administration
在这个像足球经理的领域，你知道的，多米尼克，所有那些你本该做却没做的事情。你把加尔巴对
of the ryan legions to my managerial career in the late 1990s there are managers who can be incredible sticklers for discipline and who nobody likes and then there are managers who yeah absolutely the players absolutely adore them and will do anything for them exactly galba was was was a stickler without charisma so he's not he's not alex ferguson basically he's not alex ferguson no so they don't like him um and that means that when the first of january comes and the time comes for them to go to um the principia which is the kind of the central great hall the great shrine in the middle of each legionary base to pay their respects to the standards, the eagles, that is the symbol for each legion, but also the statues of the emperor. And it's a way basically of kind of renewing,
莱茵河军团的管理与我20世纪90年代末的经理人生涯相提并论。有些经理可以对纪律要求得极其严苛，却没有人喜欢他们；然后有些经理，是的，绝对的，球员们绝对崇拜他们，会为他们做任何事。完全如此，加尔巴就是一个没有个人魅力的严厉督察。所以他基本上不是亚历克斯·弗格森（Alex Ferguson），他不是亚历克斯·弗格森。不，所以他们不喜欢他，嗯，这意味着当1月1日到来，他们该去，嗯，普林皮亚（principia）——也就是每个军团基地中央的主大厅、大圣殿——向军旗、鹰徽（每个军团的象征），以及皇帝的雕像致敬的时候。这基本上是一种更新，
you know, it's a public affirmation of loyalty to the serving emperor. And this is incredibly important this year of all years because Galba, unlike the previous lines of emperors, you know, he has no claim to be a part of the family of Augustus, who was the founder of this imperial dynasty. So for the first time, someone is ruling a Caesar who does not belong to the family of the Caesars. So you have all these all these bases. You have bases in what are called Lower Germany, which is the kind of the upper Rhine, the Rhine nearest the North Sea.
你知道的，是对现任皇帝忠诚的公开宣示。而今年这一年，这一点极其重要，因为加尔巴与前几代皇帝不同，你知道的，他没有任何宣称自己是奥古斯都（Augustus，这个帝国王朝的创立者）家族成员的资格。因此，这是第一次由一个不属于凯撒家族的人来统治凯撒。所以你有所有这些基地。你在所谓的下日耳曼尼亚（Lower Germany）有基地，也就是上莱茵河，靠近北海的那段莱茵河。
And then you have Upper Germany, which is going further towards the source. The legions of Lower Germany, with no great enthusiasm, are persuaded to basically kind of swear loyalty, swear their sacramentum, their kind of oath of loyalty to Galba. In Upper Germany, it's different. There, there is a massive troublemaker by the name of Aulus Caicina. And Caicina actually had been a colleague in Spain of Galba's. Oh, so he hates him? No, had actually kind of swung round behind him.
然后你有上日耳曼尼亚（Upper Germany），那是更靠近河源的地方。下日耳曼尼亚的军团在没有多少热情的情况下，被说服基本上向加尔巴宣誓效忠，宣誓他们的“萨克拉门图姆”（sacramentum，即效忠誓言）。在上日耳曼尼亚，情况则不同。那里有一个名叫奥卢斯·凯奇纳（Aulus Caecina）的大麻烦制造者。而凯奇纳实际上曾在西班牙与加尔巴共事过。哦，所以他恨他？不，实际上已经转而支持他了。
Oh, okay. Together with a man called Otho. He would be a friend of Nero. So Otho, Caicina. You love him. You love Otho. Otho, Caicina and Vitalius. So Otho, Caicina and Galba, between them,
哦，好吧。和一个叫奥托（Otho）的人一起。他会是尼禄的朋友。所以奥托，凯奇纳。你喜欢他。你喜欢奥托。奥托、凯奇纳和维特里乌斯（Vitellius）。所以奥托、凯奇纳和加尔巴，他们之间
had kind of mustered the forces of Spain that had then enabled Galba to become emperor. Otho had gone with Galba to Rome, but by Caecina, who was very young, had been given command of the senior legion in a double legionary base at a place called Magontiarchum, which today is Mainz. Okay. And this is a huge promotion. He's been promoted massively above his age qualifications. So Caicino should be happy with this, but he's not because he's a man in a hurry.
聚集了西班牙的军队，从而使加尔巴得以成为皇帝。奥托曾与加尔巴一同前往罗马，但非常年轻的凯奇纳被委任指挥一个双军团基地的资深军团，地点在马贡蒂亚库姆（Magontiacum），即今天的的美因茨（Mainz）。好吧。这是一个巨大的晋升。他的资历远未达标，却得到了极大的提拔。所以凯奇纳本该对此感到高兴，但他并不高兴，因为他是一个急功近利的人。
And he's stuck out in the snow and drizzle of the Rhine while Otho is back in Rome, whooping it up. And of course, as it turns out, plotting. And Caecina basically decides that he wants to expedite his career even faster. And so over the course of 69, he's been engaging in all kinds of corrupt practices and he's been caught red handed and Galba wants to bring him to trial trial and so this threatens the total ruin of his career so Caetino decides on the 1st of January he's got nothing to lose and so he stirs up a mutiny and the legion he's in command of and then the other legion that's sharing this camp
他被困在莱茵河的风雪和细雨中，而奥托却在罗马寻欢作乐。当然，事实证明，他在密谋。凯奇纳基本上决定他想以更快的速度推进自己的职业生涯。所以在公元69年期间，他一直在从事各种腐败勾当，结果被当场抓获，加尔巴想要将他交付审判，因此这威胁到他职业生涯的彻底毁灭。所以凯奇纳在1月1日决定他已经没什么可失去的了，于是他煽动了自己所指挥的军团以及另一个与他共享这个营地的军团发生哗变。
they all smash the statues of of Galba they they reject his claim to be a legitimate caesar they uh swear an oath of loyalty um not to any individual candidate because there isn't an available one but to the senate and people of rome but of course they are immediately looking around for someone else who might be able to you know know, take Galba's place. So even Caetino recognises that he can't do that. He's too young. He's too junior. He lacks the prestige to be a credible Caesar. So basically it needs to be either the governor of Upper Germany
他们全都砸毁了加尔巴的雕像，他们拒绝承认他是合法的凯撒，他们宣誓效忠，不是效忠于某一个具体的候选人（因为没有现成的人选），而是效忠于罗马元老院和人民。但当然，他们立刻开始环顾四周，看是否还有其他人能够，你知道的，取代加尔巴的位置。因此，连凯奇纳也意识到他自己做不到这一点。他太年轻了。资历太浅了。他缺乏成为一个可信凯撒的威望。所以基本上这必须是上日耳曼尼亚的总督
or Lower Germany. The governor of Upper Germany has one of the more amusingly, one of the more amusing Roman names. I mean, he's called Hordonius flaccus which i mean this kind of sounds like something out of viz yeah and he he's a hopeless figure he never does he is a flaccid figure he he's he's not a hard-on um he he basically he's he's not going to be a good caesar right so they look at the guy who is you know up the rhine who's the governor there and it's a guy called vitellius very fat now
或者是下日耳曼尼亚的总督。上日耳曼尼亚的总督有一个听起来比较滑稽的罗马名字。我的意思是，他叫霍多尼乌斯·弗拉克斯（Hordonius Flaccus），我的意思是这听起来有点像《Viz》杂志里的角色，是的，而他是一个无可救药的人物，他从不，他是一个软弱无力的人物，他不是一个“硬汉（hard-on）”——他基本上，他不会成为一个好的凯撒，对吧？所以他们看着那个家伙，也就是上莱茵河的总督，一个叫维特里乌斯的家伙，非常胖。现在
if i tell you as you say he's very very fat that's the thing isn't there something about suetonius says about him that when he was marching he'd often like stop and like eat a pie and stuff and then he loves his pies he loves his pies yeah he loves his pies or something yeah but he's a man of uh he has kind of distinguished pedigree um he's actually despite the fact that Suetonius and Tacitus both kind of blacken his name because he ends up you know he's a bit of a loser um he has you know he has a distinguished record he's perfectly serviceable as a candidate um and one of the things that's actually rather impressive about him is that he he knows his own inadequacies and so when um a messenger is sent by um uh karchina galloping all the way up to what's now cologne where vitalius has his headquarters and bursting in and of course
如果像你说的维特里乌斯，他非常非常胖，就是这样，苏托尼乌斯（Suetonius）不是说过关于他的事吗，当他行军时，他经常会停下来吃个馅饼什么的，然后他喜欢吃馅饼，他喜欢馅饼，是的，他喜欢馅饼之类的，是的，但他是一个有，他有显赫血统的人，实际上，尽管苏托尼乌斯和塔西佗（Tacitus）都抹黑过他的名字，因为他最终落得个失败者的下场，但他确实有显赫的履历，作为一个候选人他完全够格，而且他实际上相当令人印象深刻的一点是，他了解自己的不足。所以当
vitalius is at dinner which causes his amusement he's always at dinner um vitalius kind of you know says we you should become caesar vitalius hesitates uh and then the next day um one of the commanders um from his his stretch of the rhine a man called fabius valens comes rushing in from the legionary camp at bonn and likewise says you know yes you must become caesar so vitalius then faces a huge problem which is he doesn't really want to be Caesar he knows he won't be a good Caesar um his mum had been told with so the story goes when he born that if he ever had a military command it would all end up disastrously and so he's always
凯奇纳派出一个信使，一路策马狂奔到现在的科隆（Cologne）——维特里乌斯的总部所在地，突然闯进去，当然，
been conscious of this and so he's worried that you know it's this this has all been foretold that it's going to end terribly but he's got this huge problem because if he's not going to accept the leadership of the mutinous legions as their emperor then he's going to have to repress the mutiny and he doesn't have any troops so he has to go along with it yeah he's essentially stuck um and then the news comes through from Rome that Galba has been assassinated and replaced by Otho. So you have the situation in by the end of January where in Rome you have Otho on the Rhine frontier. You have Vitellius and you have troops. So both Caecina and Valens are already leading their troops southwards towards the alps uh and and italy and we are all set fair
维特里乌斯正在吃晚饭（这让他觉得好笑，他总是在吃晚饭），维特里乌斯有点，你知道的，说“你应该成为凯撒”。维特里乌斯犹豫了，然后第二天，来自他那段莱茵河防线的一位指挥官、一个叫法比乌斯·瓦伦斯（Fabius Valens）的人从波恩（Bonn）的军团营地冲了过来，同样说“是的，你必须成为凯撒”。所以维特里乌斯随后面临一个巨大的问题，那就是他其实不想成为凯撒，他知道自己不会是一个好凯撒。传说当他出生时，他母亲曾被告知，如果他指挥军队，一切都会以灾难告终，所以他一直
for a year that comes to be known as the year of the four emperors i think we should we should revisit this tom well we should because i've actually just been writing about it in the book yes i am currently in the process of so your book just to give uh listeners a sneak preview your book is about so you've done one on the Julio Claudians. So I've done Rubicon, which is about the fall of the Roman Republic. I've done Dynasty, which is about the Julio Claudians ending with Nero. And this is called Pax. So the peace, the Roman peace.
对此耿耿于怀，他担心这一切都是命中注定，会以极其糟糕的结局收场。但他遇到了一个巨大的麻烦：如果他不接受这支哗变军团作为他们的皇帝，那么他就必须镇压这场哗变，但他手下没有任何军队，所以他只能随波逐流。是的，他基本上被卡住了。然后罗马传来了消息：加尔巴被暗杀，奥托取而代之。所以到了1月底，你面临这样一种局面：在罗马有奥托，在莱茵河边境有维特里乌斯，并且你拥有军队。因此，凯奇纳和瓦伦斯都已经率领他们的军队向南进发，穿过阿尔卑斯山和意大利，我们正全速迎来
And it begins with Nero's death. We go through the year of the four emperors. So you have Galba gets murdered by Otho, who gets defeated in battle by Vitellius, who gets defeated and horribly killed by the supporters of Vespasian, who by the end of the year has become emperor. And he then establishes the Flavian dynasty, followed by Titus, who is emperor when Pompey gets destroyed, when the Colosseum is inaugurated, Domitian gets assassinated. And then you have Nerva, Trajan, Hadrian. And it's bookended by the two events that perhaps in the long run have the most seismic impact in this period,
后来被称为“四帝之年”的一年。我想我们应该，我们应该重新审视这一点，汤姆。嗯，我们应该，因为我实际上刚刚在书中写到过它。是的，我目前正在……所以你的书，为了给听众一个小剧透，你的书是关于……所以你已经写过一本关于尤里乌斯·克劳狄王朝（Julio-Claudians）的书了。我写过《卢比孔河》（Rubicon），是关于罗马共和国灭亡的。我写过《王朝》（Dynasty），是关于以尼禄告终的尤里乌斯·克劳狄王朝的。这本书叫《帕克斯》（Pax）。也就是和平，罗马和平。
which is the two Jewish revolts, the first of which culminates in the destruction of the temple. The second one culminates effectively in the destruction of the Judean quality of what gets renamed Palestine. So it's a really thrilling, important, fascinating period. A nice bit of early promotion for your book. Happy New Year.
它以尼禄的死开始。我们经历了四帝之年。加尔巴被奥托谋杀，奥托在战役中被维特里乌斯击败，维特里乌斯又被维斯帕先（Vespasian）的支持者击败并惨遭杀害，维斯帕先在年底前成为了皇帝。然后他建立了弗拉维王朝（Flavian dynasty），接着是提图斯（Titus，庞贝古城毁灭、斗兽场落成时在位的皇帝），然后是图密善（Domitian）被暗杀。然后是涅尔瓦（Nerva）、图拉真（Trajan）、哈德良（Hadrian）。它以这一时期影响最深远的两个事件作为首尾呼应，
When is it out? When's it out? Next this year? 2022? No, next year. 2023. So what are we in now? 2022.
也就是两次犹太起义，第一次起义以圣殿的毁灭告终。第二次起义实际上以被更名为巴勒斯坦的犹太地区特性的毁灭告终。所以这是一段非常惊心动魄、极其重要且引人入胜的时期。为你书做的一点早期宣传。新年快乐。
Yeah, 2023. Okay. Jolly good. That 2022? No, next year. 2023. So what are we in now? 2022. Yeah, 2023. Okay, jolly good. That's something to look forward to. Right, and what we've also got to look forward to after the break is my choice for the 1st of January. Which is also on a Roman theme, isn't it? Yeah, Roman-ish. I think we can say Roman-ish.
什么时候出版？什么时候出版？接下来今年？2022年？不，明年。2023年。那么我们现在是什么时候？2022年。
Yeah, we shall return after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
是的，2023年。好吧。好极了。那是2022年？不，明年。2023年。那么我们现在是什么时候？2022年。是的，2023年。好吧，好极了。那是值得期待的事情。好，接下来我们休息过后还要期待的是我为1月1日挑选的内容。这也是一个罗马主题，对吧？对，算是罗马主题吧。我想我们可以说是罗马主题的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com Happy New Year, everyone. Welcome back to our 1st of January, 12 Days of Christmas special. In the first half, we had a very, very Roman theme. We were looking at the mutiny on the Rhineine in ad 69 the year of the four emperors
好的，我们休息一下再回来。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一点八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
um and dominic your choice is also you know it's roman it is roman yeah it is roman so as you know tom i have a long-running sort of hobby i have a long-running passion for byzantine history which i started when i was an undergraduate and um have always been fascinated by frankly would have done if i'd had the languages but i didn't i didn't you couldn't do latin or i'd lost all my latin never really done any greek um so i couldn't do anything on it um so i ended up going to american and then british history instead but deep down i'd always like to have done the age of iconoclasm or something like that so anyway we are in we've been going all Christianity. Yeah, God, how awful that would have been. Yeah, imagine that.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、获取加更剧集并优先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大家新年快乐。欢迎回到我们的1月1日圣诞12天特别节目。在前半部分，我们有一个非常非常罗马主题的内容。我们回顾了公元69年四帝之年莱茵河的兵变。
There's an alternate reality. Maybe I'd have been a very iconoclastic historian and I'd have claimed Christianity. You said it was all about sociology. Yeah, exactly. It was all about pots. The pots, I couldn't get... I could never get on with the pots, to be brutally honest.
嗯，多米尼克，你选择的也是，你知道的，它是罗马的，它是罗马的，是的，它是罗马的。所以如你所知，汤姆，我有一个长期以来的，某种爱好，我对拜占庭历史有着长期的热情，这始于我读本科的时候，而且，坦白说，一直都很着迷——如果我懂那些语言的话我本可以研究的，但我没有，我没有，你无法修读拉丁语，或者我已经丢光了拉丁语，也从未真正学过希腊语，所以我无法研究它，所以我最后转而研究了美国史和英国史。但在心底，我一直希望自己能研究圣像破坏运动（iconoclasm）或类似的东西。所以无论如何，我们处于，我们一直在研究所有基督教。是的，天哪，那会有多可怕啊。是的，想象一下。
So you don't like pots and you don't like Christianity. Yeah. But you love to do history. I think you were much better better i just like eunuchs blinding icons all those kinds of palaces right so we are in the 11th century uh we are on the 1st of january 1068 and this is the day that a fellow called romanus the fourth becomes what we would now call the Emperor of Byzantium. But of course, they didn't grow that. Emperor of the Romans, right. Emperor of Rome.
那是一个平行现实。也许我会成为一个非常具有反圣像破坏运动风格的历史学家，我会声称基督教。你说这完全是关于社会学的。是的，完全如此。这完全是关于陶罐的。那些陶罐，我无法……说句大实话，我从来无法应付那些陶罐。
I mean, this is one of the strange things, I think, we've never really done an episode on the Byzantine Empire. But one of the interesting things about it is that it's known by name that none of the people who lived in it were Byzantians. Well, there are so many that we should do. I mean, we should do a kind of framing episode, shouldn't we? We should. We should, but then we should. I mean, we should do a kind of framing episode, shouldn't we? We should. We should, but then we should...
所以你不喜欢陶罐，你也不喜欢基督教。对。但你喜欢做历史。我觉得你做得好得多得多，我只是喜欢太监、弄瞎眼睛、圣像、所有那些宫殿，对吧？所以我们正处于11世纪，嗯，我们正处于1068年的1月1日，这就是被称为罗曼努斯四世（Romanus IV）的家伙成为我们现在所说的拜占庭皇帝的日子。但当然，他们不这么叫。罗马人的皇帝，对吧。罗马皇帝。
I mean, I've mentioned iconoclasm. I love the subject of iconoclasm because there's so little known about it. It's so mysterious. Anyway, we're kind of getting sidetracked. So in the 11th century, the Empire of the Romans has become... You know, it's waxed and waned, but it has by and large been reduced to the southern Balkans and what is now largely Turkey.
我的意思是，这是奇怪的事情之一，我想，我们从来没有真正做过一期关于拜占庭帝国的节目。但关于它有趣的事情之一是，它被称为这个名字，而生活在其中的没有一个人是拜占庭人。嗯，有太多了，我们应该做一期。我的意思是，我们应该做一期类似于框架介绍的节目，对吧？我们应该。我们应该，但接着我们应该……
So basically Asia Minor, Anatolia. But the 11th century, I mean, so it had gone through a terrible stage. So we did Charlemagne's Coronation. Yeah. And it was really on its uppers then. Yeah. But over the course of the 10th century
我的意思是，我提到了圣像破坏运动。我喜欢圣像破坏运动这个主题，因为人们对它知之太少了。它是如此神秘。无论如何，我们有点偏离主题了。所以在11世纪，罗马人的帝国已经……你知道，它几经起伏，但大体上已经缩减到了巴尔干半岛南部和现在的大部分土耳其地区。
into the 11th century, it comes back. It has come back, yes. It's had tremendous comebacks. Yeah. But it's sort of... The brilliant 10th century into the 11th century, it comes back. It has come back. Yes. It's a tremendous comebacks. Yeah. But it's the brilliant 10th century emperor, Nick, Nick, effortless forecast.
所以基本上是小亚细亚，安纳托利亚。但在11世纪，我的意思是，它曾经历过一个可怕的阶段。所以我们做过查理曼大帝的加冕礼。是的。那时它真的是穷途末路了。是的。但到了10世纪的过程中
Yeah. He's the fellow. Is he now, does he lose his head or does he sever somebody else's? I can never remember. He gets assassinated in the palace, but he's an awful Saracen fighter. There are,
进入11世纪，它卷土重来了。它确实卷土重来了，是的。它有过惊人的东山再起。是的。但它有点……那辉煌的10世纪进入11世纪，它卷土重来。它确实卷土重来了。是的。这是一个惊人的东山再起。是的。但那是10世纪杰出的皇帝尼克，尼克，不费吹灰之力的福克斯。
there are, I mean, there's all these tremendous characters, Basil, the Bulgar slayer. And so, so, so, so actually. I mean, there's all these tremendous characters, Basil the Bulgar Slayer and so on. So actually, I mean, the thing is that when Romanus IV becomes emperor, the Byzantine Empire is a massive superpower. Yeah, it's not doing that badly.
是的。就是这个家伙。他现在，是他掉了脑袋还是他砍了别人的脑袋？我总是记不清。他在宫里被暗杀的，但他是个可怕的萨拉逊人（Saracen）战士。有，
I mean, as I say, it's not the Roman Empire of Italy, North Africa, Spain and so on. It's in the eastern Mediterranean. But you're right. It's rich. It's powerful. It's a very sophisticated place. And if you think at the same time,
有，我的意思是，这里有所有这些了不起的人物，杀保加利亚人者巴西尔（Basil the Bulgar Slayer）。所以，所以，所以，实际上。我的意思是，这里有所有这些了不起的人物，杀保加利亚人者巴西尔等等。所以实际上，我的意思是，事情是这样的，当罗曼努斯四世成为皇帝时，拜占庭帝国是一个庞大的超级大国。是的，它其实过得并不差。
this is what, two years after the Battle of Hastings? I mean, the Romans, the people who live in Constantinople, are living lives of kind of gilded splendor, really, compared with their sort of northern rivals. Anyway, so this fellow, he's called Romanus Diogenes, and he's the son of a guy called Constantine Diogenes. And the Diogonoi, the family, they come from what's now Turkey, so from Anatolia.
我的意思是，正如我所说，它不是那个拥有意大利、北非、西班牙等等的罗马帝国。它在地中海东部。但你是对的。它很富裕。它很强大。这是一个非常高度文明的地方。如果你想想同时代，
They're a very sort of rich, well-connected, kind of military aristocratic family clan. And he has, you know, you talk about people serving on the frontier, the Rhine frontier. So the equivalent in the sort of 11th century is the Danubian frontier. So that's where they, the Romans of the day, have their troops. And he has served in that army. And he, it's, there are some interesting parallels between the first story
这差不多是黑斯廷斯战役（Battle of Hastings）两年后？我的意思是，罗马人，那些住在君士坦丁堡的人，与他们北方的竞争对手相比，过着某种镶金带玉般的奢华生活。无论如何，所以这个家伙，他叫罗曼努斯·狄奥根尼斯（Romanus Diogenes），是一个叫康斯坦丁·狄奥根尼斯（Constantine Diogenes）的人的儿子。狄奥根尼斯家族，这个家族来自现在的土耳其，也就是安纳托利亚。
and this story because Romanus is a very popular and successful general. The emperor Constantine X has died in 1067. His wife, who is called Eudokia, has taken over as regent for his sons who were basically too young to assume the throne themselves. And Romanus clearly thinks, as is very common with um byzantian generals in this era he clearly thinks well you know i could kind of take over myself and clearly lots of soldiers think this um but basically any plan that he has for a coup goes wrong and he is taken to constantinople and taken before Eudokia,
他们是一个非常富裕、人脉广阔、属于军事贵族阶层的家族氏族。他曾，你知道的，你谈到人们在边境服役，莱茵河边境。所以11世纪的等同物就是多瑙河边境。那是当今罗马人驻扎军队的地方。他曾在军队中服役。而且，第一个故事和这个故事之间有一些有趣的相似之处，
who is the regent, who is the widow. And he awaits punishment. Now, in these days, obviously, you could be executed. You could be blinded. You could be forced into a monastery. And the sources aren't great, but you can kind of imagine him there waiting to find out what his sentence is. And she says, actually, you know what?
因为罗曼努斯是一位非常受欢迎且成功的将军。皇帝康斯坦丁十世（Constantine X）于1067年去世。他的妻子，名叫尤多基亚（Eudokia），接管了政权，担任她那些基本上太年幼而无法自己登基的儿子的摄政王。罗曼努斯显然认为——正如这个时代的拜占庭将军们非常普遍的做法那样——他显然认为，嗯，你知道的，我可以自己接管政权，显然很多士兵也这么认为，但基本上他关于政变的任何计划都出了岔子，他被带到了君士坦丁堡，带到了
You seem quite an impressive impressive fellow i think i might marry you and you can become emperor i mean that's the best isn't it so it's basically the range of options you have yeah that's better you take that that is that you definitely take that i mean you know it's tremendous well i mean given what happens uh maybe he would think that he'd do him better off in a monastery who knows anyway he he takes he becomes emperor and actually what's interesting about him is not that this event on the first of january but what happens afterwards because as you know tom he is emperor for the next sort of three years and then he leads the roman the byzantine army, into this tremendous battle at a place called Manzikert in 1071,
担任摄政王、身为遗孀的尤多基亚面前。他等待着惩罚。现在，在那个年代，显而易见，你可能会被处决。你可能会被弄瞎双眼。你可能会被迫去修道院。史料记载并不好，但你可以想象他站在那里等待宣判。而她说，事实上，你知道吗？
where he's up against a group of people called the Turks. So obviously the Turks have come from Central Asia and they've swept into or swept or seeped. I mean, it's been quite gradual into kind of Asia Minor, into Anatolia. And they are the, they are the big new players, the Seljuk Turks. But they're, they're,
你看起来是个相当了不起的家伙，我想我可能会嫁给你，然后你可以成为皇帝。我的意思是，这难道不是最好的吗？所以基本上这就是你的选择范围，是的，这更好，你接受这个，那绝对是你会接受的，我的意思是，你知道的，这太棒了。好吧，我的意思是，鉴于后来发生的事情，也许他会觉得自己在修道院里呆着会更好，谁知道呢？无论如何，他接受了，他成为了皇帝，实际上关于他有趣的地方不是1月1日的这个事件，而是之后发生的事情。因为如你所知，汤姆，他在接下来的三年左右时间里担任皇帝，然后他率领罗马——拜占庭军队，在1071年一个叫曼齐克特（Manzikert）的地方打了一场极其惨烈的战役，
they're intimidated by the Romulus army. They know they're desperate to make terms. Yeah. I can just crush them. And, but no, because the battle of Manzikert, it all goes wrong for him.
他在那里对抗一群被称为土耳其人的人。所以很显然，土耳其人来自中亚，他们席卷进入了——或者说席卷、渗入了。我的意思是，这是一个相当渐进的过程——进入小亚细亚，进入安纳托利亚。他们是，他们是新的大玩家，塞尔柱突厥人（Seljuk Turks）。但他们，他们，
Doesn't it? Don't some of the, some of his, half the army runs away. And he split his forces, hasn't he? Yeah. So it's a classic. He's withdrawing and they, yeah, terrible.
他们被罗曼努斯的军队吓坏了。他们知道自己迫切想要媾和。是的。我可以粉碎他们。但是不，因为曼齐克特的战役，一切对他的不利都发生了。
It's all a shambles. He's captured. The Seljuk Sultan is a man called Alp Arslan. And he can't believe, Byzantine historians say he can't believe it when this guy is dragged before him and they say, this is the Roman emperor. This is the heir of Augustus and constantine and diocletian and all the justinian all these great figures and this shambolic looking man covered in dust battered and um alp arslan puts his foot on romana they push romanistan in the dust and alp arslan puts his foot on romanus
不是吗？难道他的某些，他的一半军队逃跑了吗？他分散了他的军队，不是吗？是的，这是一个典型的例子。他在撤退，然后他们，是的，太糟糕了。
his neck as a sort of symbol but then actually he treats him with what our Turkish listeners will be pleased to hear, traditional Turkish hospitality. He raises him to his – he takes him to his tent and gives him fine wines and they eat, you know, kebabs or whatever and have a splendid time. Treats him very well. Never said a cruel word to him in the eight days that romanus spent in the in the camp so basically he then releases romanus and says you'll give us a treaty and you'll pay a massive ransom romanus says oh yes absolutely then he goes back and the
这一切简直是一团糟。他被俘了。塞尔柱苏丹是一个叫阿尔普·阿尔斯兰（Alp Arslan）的人。拜占庭历史学家说，当这个家伙被拖到他面前时，他简直不敢相信，他们说，这是罗马皇帝。这是奥古斯都、君士坦丁、戴克里先（Diocletian）以及所有查士丁尼（Justinian）等伟大人物的继承人。而这个看起来一团糟、浑身是尘埃、饱经风霜的男人，嗯，阿尔普·阿尔斯兰把他的脚踩在罗曼努斯身上——他们把罗曼努斯推倒在尘土中，阿尔普·阿尔斯兰把脚踩在罗曼努斯的
the imperial family have basically launched a kind of coup against him and they they do cast family um so then there's a whole series of sort of strange feuds and battles and um romanus is he's basically holed up in adana in the south of turkey what's now turkey and uh he's surrounded and he has to surrender and he's given assurances of sort of safety and so on so he surrenders so this is the end of 1071 and um they've told him, the people who've toppled him from the sort of imperial family, they say, well, you know, we'll let you go. You can go into a monastery and stuff. But they completely break that promise, Tom. Very, very poor form.
脖子上作为一种象征，但随后实际上他用——我们的土耳其听众听到这里会很高兴——传统的土耳其热情好客对待他。他扶起他——他把他带到自己的帐篷里，给他提供美酒，他们吃烤肉串（kebabs）或者别的什么，度过了美好的一段时光。对他非常好。在罗曼努斯在军营里度过的八天里，（阿尔普·阿尔斯兰）从未对他说过一句残酷的话。所以基本上他随后释放了罗曼努斯，并说你会给我们一份条约，你将支付巨额赎金。罗曼努斯说，哦，是的，绝对的。然后他回去了，而
Very Byzantine. They break that promise. And do you know what happens to him? Remind me. Well, he is led away ple pleading for mercy, to be blinded, this is what the source says, by an inexperienced Jew who requires three attempts to blind him while the emperor bellowed like a bull. Yeah. Very sad scene. When he arose, his eyes were drenched with blood, a pathetic and pitiable sight that made everyone who saw it cry uncontrollably.
皇室家族基本上对他发动了一场政变，他们把卡斯特家族给……所以接下来是一系列奇怪的世仇和战役，嗯，罗曼努斯，他基本上被困在土耳其南部阿达纳（Adana，即现在的土耳其境内），嗯，他被包围了，他不得不投降，而且他得到了某种安全保证，所以他投降了。所以这是1071年底，嗯，那些推翻他的人——那些皇室家族的人告诉他，他们说，好吧，你知道的，我们会放你走的。你可以去修道院之类的地方。但他们完全打破了那个承诺，汤姆。表现非常非常糟糕。
And then he's sent off to exile in the Sea of Marmara, near what's now Istanbul, and his eyes get infected. He dies very quickly, doesn't he? He dies soon after. Not unsurprisingly. And the last thing that happens to him before his death is a Byzantine historian called Michael Psellus, whose book you can get in Penguin Classics. He sends him a letter.
非常拜占庭。他们打破了那个承诺。你知道他后来怎么样了吗？提醒我一下。嗯，他被拖走苦苦哀求饶他一命，要求不要被弄瞎双眼——史料就是这么说的——一个毫无经验的犹太人用三次尝试才弄瞎了他的双眼，而皇帝则像一头公牛一样嚎叫。是的。非常悲伤的场景。当他站起来时，他的双眼被鲜血浸透，那是一个悲惨而令人怜悯的景象，让所有看到它的人都无法控制地哭泣。
He hates Romanus, and he sends him a letter. He says, congratulations on the loss of your eyes. Sort of, basically, kind of mocking eyes. So basically I'm mocking, it's all about kicking a man when he's down. Yeah. Yeah. So that's the end of Romanus. And that's why I think back on New Year's day, 1068 or whenever it was,
然后他被流放到马尔马拉海（Sea of Marmara）的一个地方，就在现在的伊斯坦布尔附近，他的眼睛感染了。他死得很快，不是吗？他不久后就去世了。这并不令人意外。在他死前发生在他身上的最后一件事是，一个名叫米歇尔·普塞尔（Michael Psellus）的拜占庭历史学家（他的书你可以在企鹅经典丛书里买到）给他写了一封信。
when he went in to see the Empress. It'd have been better. He'd been a monk. He'd have been much better being a monk from the beginning. Yeah. None of this would have happened. Manzikert, losing to the Turks.
他恨罗曼努斯，他给罗曼努斯写了一封信。他说，祝贺你失去双眼。基本上就是一种嘲弄眼睛。所以基本上我在嘲弄，这完全是痛打落水狗。是的。是的。所以这就是罗曼努斯的结局。这就是为什么我回想起1068年元旦或无论那是哪天，
As of course would Byzantine empire. Yeah. Yeah. You're would have happened. Manzikert, losing to the Turks. As, of course, would Byzantine Empire. Yeah, yeah, you're right. Because really, Manzikert is, you know, it's a kind of death knell in the long run. It's a landmark, isn't it? In sort of the long history of the Roman Empire. Because it's not actually the battle itself. It's the civil war that follows.
当他进去见皇后的时候。那会好得多。他本该当个僧侣。他从一开始就当个僧侣会好得多。是的。这一切都不会发生。曼齐克特，输给土耳其人。
Yeah, it sort of tears it apart. And the Turks are able to kind of start infiltrating in. Yeah, and from that point onwards. I mean, that said, said tom they last for another 400 years but they do they do but it's um you know it's it's not great is it but they never recapture anatolia the whole no they don't it's their old heartland where they used to raise all their troops from and stuff um but even so you know i sometimes think with the strange thing with byzantine history is people sort of say after man Manzikert, it was all downhill. You kind of think, yeah, but that's kind of twice as long
正如拜占庭帝国当然也会。是的。是的。你是对的。因为说实话，曼齐克特是，你知道的，从长远来看，这是一个丧钟。这是一个里程碑，不是吗？在罗马帝国的悠久历史中。因为这实际上并不是战役本身。而是随之而来的内战。
as the United States has existed. That's a hell of a long time. It's on life support for quite a long time. So Manzikert and the capture of Constantinople in 1204 by the Crusaders. That's very poor, isn't it? That's an amazing story, but also kind of one of the most shameful stories in European history.
是的，它把它撕裂了。土耳其人得以开始渗透进来。是的，从那一刻起。我的意思是，话虽如此，汤姆，他们又持续了400年，但他们确实持续了，但这是，你知道的，这不太好，不是吗？但他们再也没有收复安纳托利亚，完全没有，不，他们没有，那是他们曾经征兵以及其他事情的老根据地，但即便如此，你知道的，我有时觉得拜占庭历史奇怪的地方在于，人们总说在曼齐克特之后，一切都在走下坡路。你会想，是的，但那是美国存在时间的整整两倍长。那是一段相当长的时间。它靠生命维持系统维持了相当长的一段时间。所以曼齐克特和1204年十字军对君士坦丁堡的攻陷。那真的很糟糕，不是吗？那是一个惊人的故事，但也是欧洲历史上最耻辱的故事之一。
It's so depressing. I can never quite bring myself to read about it. Do you think the Venetians should give back those horses? I don't. I think those days are gone. Yeah. Who would they give them back to? Exactly.
太令人沮丧了。我从来无法下定决心去读它。你觉得威尼斯人应该把那些马还回来吗？我不觉得。我觉得那个时代已经过去了。是的。他们应该还给谁？
That's the thing. Exactly. Right. That's a very doubtful. Tom, you look so crushed by that. Well, I do. I find it so depressing that I love Byzantine history up until Manzika, and then after that, I can't really bear to read about it. Do you think the world would be a better place if that empire had survived?
就是这样。完全如此。好的，这非常值得怀疑。汤姆，你看上去被打击得太厉害了。嗯，我是。我发现它太令人沮丧了，我喜欢曼齐克特之前的拜占庭历史，但在那之后，我真的无法忍受去读它。你觉得如果那个帝国幸存下来，世界会变得更美好吗？
Of course it would. It would be amazing. The Roman Empire. Roman Empire surviving in the 21st century. I think, as you know, I mourn the – I think the Austro-Hungarian Empire should still exist I think that'd be a great thing
那当然会。那会太棒了。罗马帝国。罗马帝国在21世纪幸存下来。我想，如你所知，我哀悼——我认为奥匈帝国应该依然存在，我认为那会是一件很棒的事。
I'd much rather a proper line of emperors descended from Augustus right yeah Sophia's still a cathedral it'd be amazing you could go and
我宁愿要一个源自奥古斯都的正统皇帝世系，对吧，是的，圣索菲亚大教堂依然是一座大教堂，那会太棒了，你可以去
be a kind of civil servant or something at that court well I'd have to be a eunuch but you know sacrifices have to be made I suppose do you not think
在那个宫廷里当个公务员什么的。好吧，我得当个太监，但你知道，有所牺牲嘛，我想。你不认为
they'd have done away with that by now? I'd be nervous about the blindings. Yeah, I think you would. You would. But you'd be a great, you know, you'd be a great kind of, you'd be a great bishop, wouldn't you? Bishop of Antioch or something. I can absolutely see you as that.
他们现在已经废除那个制度了吗？我对弄瞎眼睛这事会感到害怕。是的，我想你会的。你会的。但你会是一个很棒的，你知道的，你会是一个很棒的，你会是一个很棒的主教，不是吗？安提 Antioch 主教什么的。我完全能想象你成为那样的人。
That'd be a very exciting option. Going to kind of, you know, councils and debating the nature of Christ. You'd love all that. But sadly, not a career option. No, you're just doing podcasts. That career avenue's been closed off and I'm reduced to doing podcasts. On which note,
那会是一个非常令人兴奋的选择。去参加各种，你知道的，会议并辩论基督的本质。你会喜欢所有这一切。但遗憾的是，这不是一个职业选择。不，你只是在做播客。这条职业道路已经被堵死了，我沦落到做播客。在这个音符上，
we should finish, shouldn't we? We have, we've just degenerated. We so often do this. And I'm sure people have better things to do on new year's day than to listen to mad insane fantasies of what we'd do in a byzantine empire that had never fallen what would you do you'd be what general or oh tom that's so kind of you thank you um no i'd be doing something really tedious and some i thought i'd maybe i'd be a holy man on a pillar i'd be stylite i'd be stylite how about you'd be. Stylite. I'd be a stylite.
我们该结束了，不是吗？我们已经，我们刚刚堕落了。我们经常这样做。而且我确信人们在元旦这天有比听我们疯狂地、神经质地幻想我们在一个从未灭亡的拜占庭帝国里会做些什么更好的事情。你会做什么？你会做什么将军还是——哦，汤姆，你太好了，谢谢你——不，我会做一些极其枯燥的事情，我想，也许我会成为一个柱头苦修僧（stylite），我会成为一个苦修僧。怎么样，你会成为。苦修僧。我会是一个苦修僧。
How about that? You'd be a terrible stylite. No, I wouldn't be a stylite. You'd get bored. I think I'd be a hard-nosed general. I think you would. Like on the Danubian frontier. Yeah, I think you would.
怎么样？你会是一个糟糕的苦修僧。不，我不会是一个苦修僧。你会觉得无聊。我想我会是一个精明强干的将军。我想你会的。就像在多瑙河边境那样。是的，我想你会的。
Yeah. And your troops would raise you to emperor and then you'd come to a horrible end. I would. I would. And I would glide away. I would glide away smiling. You would.
是的。然后你的军队拥立你为皇帝，接着你将迎来悲惨的结局。我会的。我会的。然后我会黯然神伤地滑向终点。我会带着微笑滑向终点。你会的。
Like Peter Bale I'd be Vitellius basically, I think that's what you're trying to say isn't it? stopping for a snack on my way to the decisive showdown okay, we're going to let you get on with your new year happy new year and we shall see you again tomorrow
就像彼得·贝尔（Peter Bale）一样。我基本上就是维特里乌斯，我想这就是你想表达的意思，对吧？在决定性的决战途中停下来吃点零食。好吧，我们要让你去过你的新年了，祝你新年快乐，我们明天再见。
bye bye Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
拜拜。拜拜。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。